peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
désolé pour mieux albert qui rentrent de
mission
[Musique]
la brigade des maléfices
oh
[Musique]
non
m
o o
la brigade des maléfices ne figure sur
aucun document officiel de la préfecture
de police
personne dans le public ne soupçonne son
existence et pourtant chaque jour ces
temps le champ de ses activités bien les
enquêtes menées par les plus fins
limiers de la police judiciaire s'arrête
soudain devant l'impossible l'incroyable
le surnaturel c'est alors qu'intervient
guillaume martin pommier chef de la
brigade des maléfices sherlock holmes de
la féerie maigret de la sorcellerie
moderne experts en sciences occultes
familier de l'invisible l'inspecteur
pommier ne refuse aucune des voies
ouvertes sur l'inconnu il a accepté
d'ouvrir pour nous quelques dossiers de
nous faire participer à quelques unes de
ces étranges bancaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jojo ton pantalon d'abord qui suivit
moment où ben ali dont il est passif au
lieu de salaire de campagne en vue
d'acheter mais sa glacière la salorge
moustiques aujourd'hui un bold et elle
ne m'a pas maintenant qu'ils mangent
bon alors c'est pas besoin de moi je
vais bien je vais m'attaquer la voiture
parce que impossible ragoût jamais
reporter ou non non je compte faire le
jour même
voyons voilà alors j'ai mon saoul
définie au du goudron ni danger oui on
s'attend tous à temps or c'est pas vrai
mais comment c'est venu là ça fait on va
manger tout de suite à la rochelle il ya
une marpa de moi je cherche un peu d'eau
mais c'est vite parce que la table est
mise en réseau les retours de papa maman
oui va vite tu veux manger du saucisson
défi oui
tu es un petit coup de main
pour un peu ça fera du bien
complètent ce gouvernement
[Musique]
jojo
t'as rien entendu rien mon paquetage
écoute des rires des rires de femmes
non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
on
[Musique]
ah bah non
enfin l'accord
[Musique]
côté
au fait
[Musique]
oh
ouais
[Musique]
et oui boulot ça se précise
je l'aimé trop voilà pas trop à ça n'a
pas été facile
trois jours au cabinet des estampes la
bibliothèque nationale rien alors je
veux faire un agrandissement photo par
un ami jacques goulet c'est parce que
vous connaissez la barre au fait la mare
lô fait rire
[Musique]
violaine orane
il ya sainte armide isabelle et rosa la
voilà la mare le sous-bois la clairière
doit être tout près là la mare aux faits
[Musique]
vous me prenez bien les empreintes de
pas un vide à me porter ça ou la mort
[Musique]
c'est pas comme si on ne peut plus aller
ou non c'est bon c'est bon on a besoin
que de votre témoignage connaissez la
forêt la forêt ah ça pour la connaître
vous voyez cet arbre là bas mais il a
mon âge elle a grandi ensemble et je
fais vieux le pont et se plaint tout le
temps le soir et à ses branches qui
craquent nom prénom bien andré
profession petits commerçants
bah oui quoi je vends des lapins que je
trouve mais vous êtes braconniers quoi
photo est-ce que vous reconnaissez ses
hommes pour ne rien vous cacher monsieur
s'était plaint me disent quelque chose
aille on en voit tellement dans la forêt
de nos jours avec l'argent de ma ville
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon ils se
rassemblent à tous par celui là par
exemple à metz celui 20 j'ai vu dimanche
dernier celui là oui il avait un gars
avec lui et je leur ai bien prévenu mais
ça aurait servi à quoi tout le monde me
prend pour un fou vous l'auriez prévenu
de quoi vous non plus vous n'allez pas
me croire ainsi baisser pas si bête
si vous croyez que je vais croire que
vous allez me croire et un pari que vous
ne me croyez pas la parité que le lapin
que j'ai là dans ma budget contraint
ligue de muscadet tenu bon tout ça et
vient de belles de ses folles depuis
quelques temps savent plus tenir
tranquille
elles sont lui enfin qui elles deux qui
part des juges
- elles peuvent nous entendre elles
peuvent nous en tant qu' rose à londres
a remis des et puis il appelle violaine
des faits quoi
bah oui quoi ça qu'on s'appelle la mare
lô fait part ici c'est pas pour
aujourd'hui pourtant vous vous moquez de
moi c'est très amusant
vous êtes en train de perdre votre bail
je crois bien pour ce froid y ai pas
regardé le témoignage du gosse lic son
père a entendu les voix de femmes près
de la mare femme ça serait une affaire
de moeurs à la vôtre hop et garou je
vous crois les faits sont là c'est un
fait
est ce que ces faits ne seraient pas par
hasard des personnes disons plutôt
aguichante à ça être aguichante
elles sont exigeantes alors comme ça
vous vous croyez mais oui mon vieux
allez venez vous vous tenez à notre
disposition et aux attendus vous oubliez
votre lapin à dire un pari est un pari
vous m'en direz des nouvelles brian may
fameux fait très bien le lapin à la
moutarde
les sirènes de la mare lô fait mystère
complet la police piétine
albert nous allons bientôt entrer en
piste ils vont avoir besoin de remonter
c'est plus que probable oui mais
muselier devait d'avoir une idée doit
avoir une idée mais ils auront besoin
nous quand même pour l'instant une seule
certitude ces six hommes ont été séduits
me pour ne pas dire racoler puis ils ont
été enlevés sans laisser de traces ça
sans laisser de traces
première difficulté nous avons passé
toute la forêt au peigne fin
analyser la poussière des chemins
fouiller la moindre cabane rien mais ce
rien est la preuve que nous avons
affaire à une bande redoutablement
expertes et organiser ce que je ne vois
pas c'est le motif de ces enlèvements
les ravisseurs n'ont pas demandé de
rançon les victimes sont plutôt
ordinaire seconde difficulté
larry laffer passionnante eut procédé
jeudi va dire d'une manière assez neuve
à partir des caractéristiques physiques
psychologiques sociales du disparu
j'ai fait établir par l'ordinateur un
portrait robot du disparu
idéal taille un mais 80 h 35 ans cheveux
châtains n'est régulier lieu bleus
légère myopie situation sociale quatre
moyens caractère équilibré 3 d'aucune le
japon dans ce reflet à la rêverie à
l'imagination et georges
je vois très bien mais seulement nous
n'avançons guerre par la moindre piste
pas le moindre témoignage j'ai un témoin
mais au jeu c'est un braconnier un peu
dérangé qui prête à avoir vu des faits
tout ce n'est pas très sérieux
je me demande plutôt si je me pose la
question
mais une fois n'est pas coutume si nous
demandions son avis a pommiers n'allait
pas faire appel à ce fumiste
monsieur le principal oui excusez moi je
savais que c'était vous je m'exerce
actuellement à la transmission de pensée
c'est une gymnastique difficile non je
ne plaisante pas je vous assure tenez je
vous fais d'ici avec une netteté qui me
surprends moi même vous êtes assis dans
votre fauteuil vous avez l'appareil dans
la main droite à un crayon dans la main
gauche
mon très cher collègue l'inspecteur
muselier a pris l'écouteur il porte une
cravate jaune et des brad est le mot
attention muselier premier puisque vous
savez tout c'est pourquoi je vous
appelle je devine qu'il s'agit des
sirènes de la mare ont fait exactement
nous serions heureux de voir votre avis
sur le problème muselier a entendu un
témoin qui prétend avoir eu d'effet et
maintenant elle m'a il n'en croit rien
naturellement moi non plus des dix
personnes je pense de sens et vous vous
pourriez peut-être vous interrogez
c'était moi avec vous méthode le mettre
en confiance
discrètement bien sûr muselier se fera
un plaisir de vous communiquer le
dossier parfait le principal je serai
demain matin sur les lieux du maléfice
de dix ans de l'enlèvement pour
l'instant c'est ça avoir 1er mai et
bonne chance
à vous de ce pommier parfois des
intuitions surprenante pour faire
réparer ce tabouret
alors n'ai pas vu passer un homme qui
courait oui il est parti par là dessus
au fait qu'est ce que vous faites là
vous de si bonne heure
et là on vient chercher les champignons
s'est pas défendu non champignons
je crois que j'ai des remerciements à
vous faire et pas du tout si c'est tout
naturel si six premiers garon ce que
vous avez fait là ça ne s'oublie pas
albert garros si je peut vous être utile
n'hésitez pas et bien justement vous
connaissez bien la forêt mais ça ça pour
la connaître
j'ai pour les champignons suivez moi
j'aurai quelques renseignements à vous
demander l arroser la mare au fait vous
connaissez
encore des champions
les entendais ce matin elle était tout
excité et je n'ai pas bien compris ce
qu'elle disait c'était une sorte de
chanson de conti ne sais pas elles
étaient autour de rose à la main
vous savez là la plus jeune jolie et
elle disait attendez que je me rappelle
la à oui voilà elle disait rosa l'un
d'eux se baignent dans du sel d'argent
des révélations se prépare répéter s'il
vous plaît rosa l'inde se baignent dans
du sel d'argent des révélations se
prépare à mon sens ça ne veut rien dire
bon bah messieurs s'il n'y a que ça pour
vous faire plaisir bien le salut au
revoir monsieur howard yahoo et bonne
chasse
en effet ça ne veut pas dire grand chose
mais ça peut être utile
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
c'est
mais
patron on aurait dû amener qu'à la pêche
prenez la moto et suivez le je veux
savoir qui il est où ils habitent ce
qu'il fait c'est très important mais vos
patrons comment entrer vous vous en
faites pas pour moi je me débrouillais
[Musique]
allons messieurs c'est fini vous pouvez
sortir
camouflage été parfait un modèle du
jarret pas mal non plus votre cou du
photographe
je vois que vous n'hésitez pas à
employer nos bonnes vieilles méthodes
vous lâchez votre type dans la clairière
et vous espérez que les ravisseurs vont
se manifester
malheureusement ça n'a pas marché faut
dire que votre équipe ne ressemblait pas
du tout pas du tout au portrait robot
des disparus a dit me demander conseil
on la prochaine fois je n'y manquerai
pas croyez lui est en route août à
propos votre braconniers bien sûr vous
avez pu en tirer des choses
extraordinaires pour des histoires de
bonnes femmes à dormir debout au gaz
naturel
au fait vous allez pouvoir me ramener à
paris je n'ai plus mon chauffeur quand
il faut que vous rendre service
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
allez patron s'appelle jacques lancelot
il habite 16 rue charlemagne il est
photographe et travaille dans un journal
dont je vais vous apporter un exemplaire
et voilà voilà
chaque lancelot ses limites et son
modèle vous trouvez pas patron qu'elle
ait fait éric lebel
c'est entendu mais c'est eric
[Musique]
bonsoir
le trois quart temps et non pas deux
[Musique]
et
la neige
[Musique]
s
oui
[Musique]
vidéo reste et je te fasse pour guy mais
j'en sais rien moi
garantissez j admets des pissenlits
aulas on a mangé guerre justement c'est
des travaux les jours la même chose
c'est lassant
[Musique]
huawei
je me mets au noir famille
[Musique]
on
jaffer est arrivé je la pose devant
pratos et liberté que celle ci sans la
photo mais il faut dire que tu sais pas
[Musique]
et ça c'est lille 900 membres assument
alors c'est toi luce a battu tombe bien
figure toi que jacques me trompe mais
non je ne fais pas d'idées j'en ai la
preuve
la preuve photographique mais non je
m'en fais pas va j'ai du courage il en
faut
on va au revoir se rappelleraient c'est
lui alors tu avoues
[Musique]
et
les riffs rock je te rendre la pareille
que je me mette à poser pour arthur il
ne manque que c'est arthur oms pour qui
tu voudrais que tout moi la paix à la
victoire ouais ça va bien dis-moi la
pellicule que tu m'as donné a été bien
vierge
oui on non non seulement si elles
étaient neuf bah oui je t'expliquerai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c' est déjà debout
toujours utile t'inquiète pas il est
encore très tôt
allez d'or
tous
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on fait patron lui non un
très bon sens nous avons mieux à faire
police madame nous recherchons un
individu dangereux s'ils allaient dans
le quartier vos nom prénom profession l
english est dans le métier on l'appelle
musidora si mannequin de mode vous
permettez nous jetons un coup d'oeil
c'est amusant de semaine dans du sel
d'âge
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
oui
et
didon victor tu peux me développer cette
bobine d'urgence cinéma maintenant
enfin non sont des essais que j'ai fait
ce matin j'en ai besoin très vite
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est belle n'est ce pas qu'est ce
que vous faites ici
et puis d'abord qu'est de vous excuser
moi je ne me suis pas présenté mais
maintenant que vous dirai rien si j'ai
pris la liberté d'assister rabat trois
projections c'est que le problème qui
vous préoccupent ne m'est pas étranger à
vrai dire je suis même un peu
spécialiste de ce genre de problème
le photographe pas exactement je dois
dire que la performance technique est
tout à fait remarquable dans la brume
sans visibilité
vous voulez vous en venir nulle part
nulle part je souhaite simplement vous
mettre en garde votre véhicule est très
sensible plus sensible que l'uimm
oui et alors alors alors rien que
comptez vous faire maintenant est ce que
ça vous regarde mais
dans un domaine où l'on ne peut
progresser que d'une manière très peu de
hors jeu pourrait utilement vous
conseillez tenez voici ma carte
promettez moi de venir me voir avant de
tenter quoi que ce soit de nouveau vous
entend parfaitement
alors tu marche lentement
c'est bien entendu lentement le
dispositif est en place à la moindre
alerte aux inters de nous bien sûr je
commence ma progression
attention le t'énerve pas avancent
lentement
c'est un homme se cache se rapproche je
le distingue très mal 50 mètres à peine
bientôt atteindre la mare attention
monsieur n'avançait plus il que vous
prévenir
elle vous y êtes et encore vous s mais
ça fait deux fois dans la semaine je
sais rien moi je voulais prévenir le
gras avec son chapeau et commence encore
vous mais qu'est ce que vous faites là
bas je me le demande
voyez on veut rendre service mais c est
vous j'ai bien envie de vous faire
inculper pour vagabondage et complicité
d'enlèvement endemol a pu aller à paris
dont l'une est pas moins répandu tout
est bien trop de bruit ça me donne la
migraine wever à des cachets
on
[Musique]
si je vous comprends bien patron il n'y
a pas de frontières entre la féerie et
la réalité
il vient mais une médocains la franchise
des aimants les rêveurs les poètes les
imaginatifs et les policiers
c'est beaucoup plus rare et en sens
inverse comme un sens inverse
oui si une fait envie de devenir réel au
sam paraît possible aussi quelque chose
me dit que des vedettes de
cinématographe comme greta garbo ava
gardner marlène marilyn bébés sont des
faits qui ont choisi la réalité les gens
sont curieux albert à tout bout de champ
ils disent c'est fantastique c'est
féerique
c'est d'une beauté surnaturelle et quand
on leur met le nez dessus
ils ne veulent pas en convenir
halo 3 1er mai haut lieu est en train
d'interroger garou le braconnier je
crois votre présence nous serait utile
bon elles reprenant par le début vous
reconnaissez formellement ces six hommes
jeunes et reconnaît et ils ont disparu
devant vous et ont complètement
quelqu'un les a dû relever bonjour
d'hier le premier restait ainsi ne vous
occupez pas de moi mais je disait
quelqu'un les ados relevé sûrement oui
mais vous ne savez pas qui c'est non ils
te ment c'est ça qui m'étonne au début
vous nous avez parlé de faits ce n'était
pas sérieux n'est ce pas non bien sûr
tout le monde sait que les filles ça
n'existe pas que c'est bon pour les
enfants et encore albert vous avez le
numéro de ce photographe jacques
lancelot au corps ce mode là noté joue
pas 887 30
comment 22 abbas est de circonstance
merci elmer
[Musique]
pommier que je vous fais remarquer que
vous troublez l'interrogatoire excusez
moi mais le nier mais c'est très
important entre fans de halo musidora
jacky partie ya deux heures
il m'a dit qu'il avait été faire une
course il a emporté quelque chose avec
lui
oui il a emporté le magnétophone il m'a
dit que c'était pour le faire réparer
merci monsieur le principal une nouvelle
disparition se prépare nous n'avons que
peu de temps
vous allez les patrons procédure
d'urgence immédiate vous partez pour
rambouillet j'ai bien baisse et moi
qu'est ce qu'on fait de moi vous partez
avec nous un 5 4 3 2 1 0 5 4 3 2 0
je m'appelle rosalen
je suis une fille tu m'a surpris j'étais
tranquille et je me suis prêt ce qui
nous arrive est impossible je ne devrais
pas de parler tu ne devrais pas
m'entendre
[Musique]
il est drôle pour le même cet inspecteur
du soulier
roy parfait
et ma femme qui m'attend
justement ce soir nous avons des cavités
même pas mal que savait pour un homme un
peu lourd mais pas comme tous les ans
mais pas mal tout de même
mes soeurs se moque de moi je préfère
les beaux garçons un peu idiot je vous
trouve un lingot toi garou
comment faire pour attirer les hommes
dans leurs robes à elles sont des trucs
et trocs à elle le type droit sans
dormir
ça se passe entre temps s'arrête
voyez
puis 18
si vous voulez me voir il faut fermer
les yeux attention tous ne le font pas
crispés les paupières qu'on retrouve
entre en vous comme nous légère jeu
gouttes de pluie qui ferait de votre
front sur votre visage sur votre corps
maintenant avancer tout au fond de
l'ombre il y un point lumineux comme une
clairière dans la forêt elle quitté la
liste lui avancer doucement fortement
à
[Musique]
voilà messieurs une nouvelle disparition
vient de se produire il ya quelques
instants
il s'agit de jatte lancelot photographe
de mode demeurant à paris 16 rue
charlemagne sa cirrhose à l'inde tout à
fait son genre vous pouvez prouver ce
que vous dites très simplement
voulez-vous me photographier cette allée
s'il vous plaît cette année oui
moi
[Musique]
albert vous pouvez ranger le dossier de
me promener ça aussi
tous
ok
et ellis paru patron les disparus ah oui
les disparus entre et monsieur le
principal albert un siège pour me selon
nos relations
voilà je viens vous voir au sujet vous
prendrez bien une tasse de thé monsieur
je m'en sers c'est au sujet du thé à la
menthe
il met fournie par un vieux berbère que
j'ai connu quand j'étais dans le sud
marocain au sujet des disparus de
disparus oui ah oui de disparus
oui tout ça très beau ce moment j'ai des
jeux des renseignements à fournir aux
familles des victimes en fin des délais
ce parent et deux disparus et surtout à
leur femme
tous avouent leur lait était très très
délicat
ne craignez rien ne craignez rien ils
reviendront les disparus ils reviendront
oui le reviendront ils reviendront
discrètement sur la pointe des pieds
merci albert et comme des adolescents
qui ont fait une fugue
c'est la sphère de quelques semaines
[Musique]
dis dans mon chéri je vais les chercher
un peu douala marin tue pas mais je
t'accompagne et les offres
pour
[Musique]
auger voilà voilà
ce soit
oh
[Musique]
on
oh
non
bon
[Musique]
m
oh
[Applaudissements]
désolé pour me albert qui rentrent de
mission
[Musique]
la brigade des maléfices
abou
[Musique]
ans
oh
la brigade des maléfices ne figure sur
aucun document officiel de la préfecture
de police
personne dans le public ne soupçonne son
existence et pourtant chaque jour ces
temps le champ de ses activités bien les
enquêtes menées par les plus fins
limiers de la police judiciaire s'arrête
soudain devant l'impossible l'incroyable
le surnaturel c'est alors qu'intervient
guillaume martin pommier chef de la
brigade des maléfices sherlock holmes de
la féerie maigret de la sorcellerie
moderne experts en sciences occultes
familier de l'invisible l'inspecteur
pommier ne refuse aucune des voies
ouvertes sur l'inconnu il a accepté
d'ouvrir pour nous quelques dossiers de
nous faire participer à quelques unes de
ces étranges bancaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh mais entendu un quad jour un coup de
feu n'a écouté que soit la personne ne
disait à vie comme d'habitude
aleo dormir nous avons un sacré bout de
chemin fer demain de l'arrivée du coup
tu veux marcher peeters
j'ai entendu aussi ce coup de feu
n'était pas un coup de feu c'était une
porte qui claque et au troisième mais je
t'assure enfin je recommande une
détonation
enfin puisque je te le dis franchement
qu'est-ce que vous avez vous êtes tous
pas qu'est ce que c'est tu es ma faim
t
téléphoner mais oui mais oui bien sûr
mais tout de suite sur le monde
merci
[Musique]
j'avais bien dit de toi toujours
apparaissant à la place qu'il faut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
ensuite ce que voulait savoir de plus
monsieur le commissaire je les tue et
j'avoue ça devrait vous suffire
surhaussement je comprends que tout cela
soit très pénible pour vous mais il nous
faut des explications des déclarations
circonstanciées le mettront près voilà
ce que vous voulez savoir
malheureusement très important pour vous
monsieur rocheman dans votre intérêt il
faudrait que vous puissiez établir les
mobiles le passionnel duc vous étiez
mariée depuis peu de temps
six mois vous étiez sûr évidemment de
son infidélité s'est passé tous les
soirs chez moi au début je n'y prêtais
pas attention du petit à petit juste
j'ai surpris leurs regards regarde en
dessous elle rougit sais c'était cousu
de fil blanc ce jeu comme vos amis alami
lui 56 chez vous qui venez de me dire
qu'il venait chez vous tous les soirs
oui a le talent fait tôt le feuilleton
[Applaudissements]
quel temps fut ton de la télé
tiens je vois encore qui venait me
narguer tous les soirs avec son smoking
ses chemises de dentelle son briquet en
or soner de fils à papa
jérémy parsy charmy par la fée c'est la
marge en champagne caviar tout ce luxe
ça pouvait que lui monter à la tête bien
sûr monsieur le commissaire moi je suis
con pauvres employés
mais attendez attendez vous voulez dire
que votre femme vous tromper avec un
acteur de télévision
la carce s'il avait pu il se serait jeté
dans le poste dans leur joint et bien
sûr vous pensez qu'il se retrouvait dans
la journée je pense pas j'en suis
certain monsieur le commissaire faisait
des signes elle comprenait inclus
si curieuse affaire il est jaloux d'un
acteur de feuilleton la louve au point
de tuer sa femme si ce n'était pas
tragique ce serait comique
enfin son avocat n'aura pas de peine a
plaidé l'irresponsabilité c'est un fou
c'est évident
avez vous vraiment qu'il soit fait
quelque chose de curieux dans cette
affaire elle me rappelle d'autres des
crimes passionnels ou la télé avait elle
a joué un rôle
ces pommiers qui m'en avait parlé
je me souviens maintenant bien sûr la
télé qui tue le bénéfice parfait de
crime électronique
c'est du pommier à l'étape mieux attendu
attendu 16 ça m'intriguait je lui en
toucher deux mots aussi si vous
permettez continuent elles interviennent
ensemble
entrée bonjour monsieur le principal
vous dérange pas d'enchère premiers pas
du tout au contraire
j'allais justement vous appelez au sujet
d'une affaire qui m'intrigue la sphère
roches mange pas exactement dire je vais
satisfaire votre curiosité
il est encore une fois question de
télévision ou dans le récit de
l'assassin un acteur ou un personnage de
feuilleton aurait séduit sa femme là la
victime
alors ici est assez embrouillée l'homme
n'est pas tout à fait dans son état
normal at il parlé d'une chaîne
particulière spécial la septième chaîne
je ne pense pas pourquoi il en était
question dans les précédentes affaires
enfin plus ou moins
il faudrait vérifier les comptes rendus
des interrogatoires quelque part mais je
vais appeler muselier albert demandé au
téléphone l'inspecteur muselier je vous
prie pour monsieur le principal il va
vous le passez tout de suite
vous avez muslim chez le principal
m
l'homme a alors muselier mes patrons
malheureusement votre feuilleton
c'était sur la première ou la deuxième
est l'une ni l'autre
c'était la septième bah oui quoi la
septième chaîne est l'une ni l'autre
patron c'était sur la 7ème la septième
chaîne
votre sentiment pour mieux vous croyez
que le 7e chez vous n'êtes pas sans
ignorer le caractère magique du chiffre
là vous croyez à l'intervention du
surnaturel dans cette affaire il y à là
quelque chose de dire en ce qui concerne
en tout cas l'enchaînement des
circonstances
albert je vais avoir besoin de vous
madame crochet monsieur crochet et le ca
golo envoyé spécial de crime magazine je
viens au sujet du mort on met entre
aidants monsieur vous venez pour les
détails comme le dit oui pour les
détails je crois que c'est grâce à vous
que l'assassin a été arrêté grâce à nous
a donné c'est bien simple ils étaient
ils étaient là exactement vous appuyez
le revolver à la main braqués sur moi
j'arrive à bien recharger ou pouvons
croire c'était pourtant un brave gars y
arriver j'ai tissé une fois les ti lui a
pris fin il était blanc comme un linge
alors moi je le regarde droit dans les
yeux dans les yeux et je me lève
doucement
oui mais il est bien avancé à présent et
c'est pas le tout tué sa femme son jeu
conséquence noté que dans ces moments là
on se passe son envie surtout les mois
passent attendu le coup de feu elle
voulait pendre quoi ils disaient que
c'était une porte qui avait claqué au 3e
rang mais lui veut toujours avoir raison
avant sa conduite
si j'ai bien compris vous plaît j'ai
bien compris la sas se tenait là il faut
monsieur vous êtes levés gommer ça
messieurs le petit monsieur rocheman il
avait rien d un assassin a toujours
complaisant ema europe
il faut voir comme il l'est mais sa
petite femme il avait installé la
machine à laver la télévision un
réfrigérateur et visions d'avenir
l'occasion aux mais c'était pas
n'importe quel poste il m'avait dit
qu'avec son post qui pouvait prendre la
septième chaîne schéma présenté à ce
pauvre garçon mais de la tuer sa femme
vous de même pas exagérer mois avec moi
ce poste il est encore là au match était
l'occasion je vous dis
le lendemain du crime ils sont venus
leur prendre ils sont venus mais qui ça
il a les gens ni magasin n'est pas
johnny si ça vous intéresse il remarquer
moi j'ai déjà tout ce qu'il me faut mais
pour la septième chaîne on sait jamais
peut-être un jour mais oui je nomme faut
vivre avec son temps
désolé les voies figurez vous que pour
mieux s'intéresse de très près à la
télévision avec lui je me paraît tout
non c'est cette fois c'est très sérieux
il veut un poste dernier modèle l'endive
est ce que je vote du budget prévu pour
ça peut-être se contenter d'un poste de
location sait jamais très bonne idée
je vais me faire un plaisir de lui
suggérer votre proposition
halloween pommier l'appareil
moi j'ai reçu le principal vous avez
reçus ma petite note un poste en
location oui c'est une idée de muselier
c'est que ce poste je devrais lui faire
subir beaucoup de modifications
je les patrons et une seconde vous
permettez monsieur le principal un post
en location me convient parfaitement
c'est une excellente idée oui vous
voudrez bien remercier pour moi ce cher
muselier je suis actuellement sur la
piste d'un très bon loueurs bon alors je
vous enverrai la facture tous les mois
si vous le permettez attendu beelzebub
radiotélévision location de téléviseurs
avantages spéciaux aux jeunes mariés
diables verts gérante
[Musique]
nous
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour un renseignement monsieur
n'ont ni crainte c'est gratuit dans une
pub pour une location
seriez-vous jeunes mariés un hasard nous
visons des conditions toute particulière
aux jeunes couples la maison et
sentimentale
non non non non non je regrette je suis
célibataire pour l'instant ah bon j'ai
pour toi l'arrêt manche d'une location
dont les locations c'est ici voilà
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui oui je suppose que le rendu des
couleurs différents postes à l'autre et
où il marque à l'autre mais oui de nos
appareils sont réglés pour avoir la
meilleure réception pas s'il pourra
trouver se marre ont un peu marre ont dû
la veste et marron alors mais on peut
régler voyez-vous le mois toute façon
c'est pas la couleur des matiéres mais
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le noir et
blanc
et bien c'est parti passer notre
meilleur combien de chaînes sur celui-là
6 seulement 6 comment seulement 6 c'est
l'opportunité de vous monsieur non enfin
oui justement je cherche un poste de
télévision mais jourdain une chose de ne
pas trop cher le moins cher aussi du
coup seriez-vous pas joué de marly et
base ainsi justement je vais me marier
c'est merveilleux où tombait à pic
justement des conditions particulières
au jeune couple
ça m'intéresse parce qu'évidemment si je
pouvais avoir une petite réduction ya
beaucoup luxe location-vente aucun
apport personnel au départ avant une
bouchée et en prime je vais droit vos
émissions expérimental de la septième
chaîne septième chaîne c'est encore un
secret je compte sur votre discrétion
oui oui ça et voir ce merveilleux objet
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
et puis comme écran vous n'avez rien de
plus plat fait rare c'est extra plat
mais les deux plus petits plus petits et
plus fins et futile mais essayez de
oui il vous le ramenez si ça ne va pas
célébrer vêlage moi je vous conseille
d'aller le plus loin le plus plat
portable au point de vue j'avais très
bien mais je tombais livraison je le
prends en jupe renvoyer lequel le belge
le plus petit plus plein de vie alors
que le plus pâti de ses plats non je
sépare d'une mariée bon ben je le prends
et nous le livrer à cette adresse
j'essaie georges ans
[Applaudissements]
maison belge de gand a déjà la
télévision merveilleux la matière voilà
vous tiendrez vous la mettez sur le
petit meuble à beaufonds s'il vous plaît
parfait merci vous voulez voir quelque
chose
ac non non non je vous remercie on n'a
pas fini la journée
s'il vous plaît monsieur pommier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle prend le poste
ils arrivent oh oui ils montent à près
du lit par ici monsieur pas mieux ici
voilà très bien par ici on va se poser
sur la table où la règle
il vendrait bien quelque chose messieurs
à ses palmiers gégé est muté à la manque
il nous avons aussi de l'eau-de-vie
tibétaine c'est spécial c'est de
l'alcool de riz mais ces délices que
vous vous allez voir vous allez goûter
les services et messieurs élevé non
tout au long de la journée vous devez en
faire des livraisons poste ça pour andy
warhol you 18 à 20 tous les jours avec
chants pendant le métier de la
télévision c'est l'avenir il paraît que
vous avez une forte clientèle de jeunes
ménages
well patron leur fait des réductions la
maison et sentimental comme il dit il
faut les voir les amoureux avec leurs
premières moquette toute neuve leur
canapé lit et leurs premières
télévisions sont attendrissants
récemment vous avez livré un poste un
jeune ménage on arrive tellement tu te
souviens toi
à première vue comme ça non
[Musique]
oh
vous
ou autre
si la témoin je sois nous commençons une
nouvelle série v 31 mai les deux
moniteurs les expériences incidents ont
été des concurrentes ce soit ne verra
pas pu alors ce que je veux et ligoté
retranché
nous allons faire un essai sylla
bon
mais attendez
oui oui je vous entends très bien et
très bien bossé 12 tenez vous prêts
[Musique]
attention ils ont commencé leur vingt
minutes
tiens parce que j'ai trop voté
elles sont très jolies pertinents il est
enfin à tiassalé ils ont livré la télé
tu as fait de la soupe ce soir oui c'est
bon j'aime bien ça les tarifs préparer
le potage attention encore dû consommer
de tomates
décidément le scénario change toi
oui mais la télé direct lors du journal
je crois que j'ai beaucoup mieux de
proposer quelques serres ses émissions
expérimental sur la septième chaîne
qu'est ce que c'est que c est la
septième chaîne je poste de vendeur qui
m'a dit ça c'est un truc nouveau service
l'intérieur parce que comme chez nous
[Rires]
aussi
[Musique]
délicieuse de consommer des tomates vous
ne pouvez pas ma chère tu sais c'est de
la soupe en sachet anne fait rien je
trouve ça très bon on ne trouve pas
qu'elle ait choisi lui n'est pas mal non
plus aux qpc de me rendre jaloux mais ça
marche pas pas du tout c'est toi qui a
commencé vous êtes particulièrement
ravissant ce soir mon âge mais j'ai très
envie de vous embrasser comme ça tout
bêtement tout bêtement
voilà parfait parfait bien
[Musique]
mais hubert bay allez allez je subis
c'est le moment mais regard caméra
[Musique]
oh
nous
ce qui prend au regard une idée une
impression suite moi comme ça tu peux
pas me dire maintenant puisque j'ai dit
que c'est rien
on met assez de télé pour aujourd'hui
mais bien alors qu elle avait grillé pas
mal et moi j'aime ça tenez voilà boucher
signé la
didon je trouve pas ça bizarre
quoi quoi donc j'ai pas cette ambiance
secret zh
ces émissions personne ne voit c'est pas
moi sur des corses ce même scénario que
les mois cependant le mortel on ne sait
pas se plaindre ils n'ont pas une même
dire qu'ils nous payent très bien c'est
normal ou pas normal un mois je préfère
ça que je tonds minables qu'on fait dans
des feuilletons idiot pas toi tu
regrettes les féliciter remarque m ouais
normal
alors demain soir nous reprenons la
scène où nous l'avons laissé coi
toujours dans le même état d'esprit
gilles ducharme et les inquiéter
d'accord bon alors naturellement sommes
pas question de révéler à qui que ce
soit lé nos activités méthode que j'ai
mis au point
doit rester rigoureusement secrète
attention la moindre indiscrétion de
votre part et notre contrat régulier
non mais je veux pouvoir confiance en
nous on n'avait pas peur
[Musique]
non
mon
oui
[Musique]
non
elle perd le tour de vis
[Musique]
à
non répond vous l'avez on sait pas la
septième chaîne
mais est ce que c'est moi je ne sais pas
moi la télévision martienne peut-être un
peu trop moqué de moi mais c'est aussi
la septième chaîne et cesser ses
émissions mais c'est au point je suis
prêt j'ai encore quelques petits
réglages de détail en cours d'émission
de m'asseoir je me sois un peu de
patience and bear soir mais bien qu est
ce que ça sent bon
à tétouan ces prêts tout de suite moi ça
tombe bien parce que j'ai une deuxième
phase au soir elle nouvelles jupes
bon allez joly dit non
ce qu'on attend que j'ai faim surtout
qu'il a l'air bien mais cela ne fait
rien très bientôt prêt à embaucher dans
ma vie pain alors que je m'en allais
alors oui d'accord
oui bien oui d'accord sinon ils ont maté
les miens avec toi certaines il est
délicieux vous trouvez pas je vais vous
demander de fermer les yeux juste un
tout petit instant voilà ne bougez pas
petit instant et vert mais c'est
ravissant en mer c est si vous n'avez
pas oublié comment pourrais-je oublier
les jours de m au premier rang pour
travailler
[Musique]
en plus je t'ai pas oublié dans un
téléfilm on sait évidemment ce ne sont
pas des pères j'ai pas encore des moyens
de t'offrir ça y'a que l'intention qui
compte
je t'embrasse par l'intervention
intentions un jour enfin que ce soit
phrase tu te sers avec très très jolie
suis très coûteux plaies de la scène
magnifique
[Musique]
nous ici règle
pression
et voilà mon cher albert la septième
chaîne la télévision du dia mais qu'est
ce qu'ils font là patron eh bien ils
mangent comme vous voyez ça met en
appétit moi aussi font n'auriez pas des
sandwichs ici
[Musique]
c'est tout ce que j'ai passé à merci
albert regarder mais bien est-ce qu'il
faut me les retrouver il suppose que ce
sont des comédiens professionnels
vous supposez ne joue pas mal on vient
de trouver comment faire
en fait la chine doivent être fichés
quelque part il ya des risques
d'artistes peut-être même des années
avec des photographies une bousculade
regardez comment il sort est assez de
jeunes à retrouver de le reconnaître
[Rires]
[Musique]
eh bien je te prête à faire tout ça des
bijoux
je vous annonce que tu y penses toi
aussi tu ferais bien manger du homard
porter des diamants qui se dit qu'avec
moi c'est pas demain la veille
j'écoutais antoine tu t'imagines
n'importe quoi cette télévision qui nous
donne des signes entraîné de l'état
naturel va encore nous gâcher une fois
j'ai gâché la soirée
[Musique]
à
rêviez l'enfant merci car ils ont été
remis aux très bons être ta religion est
la sienne du code yearbook bons pourront
de connaître alors du monde parfait
mais élevé à quoi ou à qui essayez vous
de ressembler j'ai un metteur en scène
de cinéma et pourquoi je vais faire les
tournées des imprésarios excellente idée
oh non non je ne vois pas a très bien
très bien sûr très bien oui mais
occupées ah bon donc toute façon il ne
correspond pas à mes personnages ou que
je prépare à fuy mali rica film art
éthique et je veux un couple a qu un
couple chic triché il est gris
anthracite et noval aa non un grand
jeune homme clair aux yeux
non non non une jeune femme blonde aux
yeux bleus jean louis boyer voilà les
brunes croyez moi est le blog
ah oui avec une perte peut-être - a
c'est tout ce que vous avez
non j'ai beaucoup mucho à démontrer mais
ça fait cheap mais montrez moi je vous
en prie je d'après deuxième choix à il
ya un an
voyons voyons un pour un personnage
poétique vous n'y pensez pas pardon
merci
prenez un jeune homme capable de porter
le smoking une jeune femme capable de
porter la robe du soir une jeune femme
blonde aux yeux clairs pas très grande
puis c'est un homme vraiment vraiment
vous ne me comprenait pas c'était c'est
moi regardez moi même non non non ils
sont qui sont occupés voilà bernois
disease lio découle non olivier la rue
sybille
muselier sybille l'heure des photos et
alors qu'est ce que ça pousse ça prouve
l'existence de la septième chaîne
ces comédiens ne sont plus produits sur
les antennes de la télévision depuis
cinq ans votre assassin a bien dû les
voir quelque part non qui ça franchement
c'est un fou le savez bien il est
enfermé dans un hôpital psychiatrique
monsieur le principal l'affairés grave
plus grave que vous ne le pensez j'ai
toutes les raisons de croire qu'un
nouveau crime de même nature se prépare
il faudrait montrer ses photos un
rocheman pour qu'ils reconnaissent son
rival
voilà je vous remercie
monsieur relâchement
monsieur rocheman franchement
connaissez-vous cet homme
c'est lui le commissaire or des
commissaires je vous raconte pas
d'histoires c'est en mètres eu ma vie ma
petite frite ou calmez-vous mon vieux
calmez vous nous allons empêcher de
nuire désormais vous ne trouvez pas que
vous y allez un petit peu fort tout de
même après tout c'est sa femme s'est
laissée séduire par un tracteur et un
petit peu de sa faute et de la tuer ce
n'est pas si simple mon cher muselier
faudrait d'abord savoir si l'acteur la
connaissais pas ce cas votre avis il
pouvait la séduire son avance jamais vue
sur l'histoire dessous écoutez muselier
ce n'est pas difficile qu'on recompte
comme il via s'il connaissait rocheman
et sa femme bonjour suite
denis rocheman terrestre
on va tourner c'est pas des personnes
qui sont sur ces photos pas du tout je
ne les ai jamais vus non mais bien sûr
eu pourtant semble bien vous connaître
bon eh bien je vais être obligé de
procéder à une petite confrontation
[Musique]
sa lecture et aux deux structures et
semble bien de connaître c'est un fou
enfin voulez vous m'expliquer ce que
cela signifie ça me sens obligé de
vérifier toutes les déclarations qu'on
nous fait même si ceux qui les font ne
sont pas tout à fait dans leur état
normal
enfin pourquoi cet homme mort et il
prétend que vous avez séduit sa femme
dans un feuilleton de télévision or nous
avons vérifié mais pas paris sur les
antennes de la rtbf depuis au moins cinq
ans
alors qu'en pensez vous vous avez une
autre explication
écoutez je n'avais jamais rencontré
cette maman aujourd'hui sa femme je n'ai
jamais rencontré non plus
c'est à vous de me donner des
explications je suis premier qui vient
de prendre l'affairé en main vous
expliquera sa beaucoup mieux que moi
bonsoir monsieur la rue je vous
raccompagne monsieur la rue ah je vous
prierais de ne pas quitter paris sans
nous prévenir
[Musique]
je présente ma femme c'est pommier je
vous connais madame je vous ai déjà
causé sa colère au terrain propre hôtel
je vous ai vu hier soir vous étiez
remarquable monsieur la rue beaucoup de
naturel de finesse
comment vous m'avez vu beaucoup
d'élégance dans votre façon de manger
l'homme
je ne comprends pas que vous gâcher
votre talent dans des entreprises aussi
suspecte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai tout lieu de penser qu'un set
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
vous
écoutez la rue
hier vous étiez des instruments entre
ses mains mais à présent vous savez je
compte sur vous pour me prévenir dès que
notre intervention sera nécessaire
écoutez nous viennent toujours la veille
le scénario de l'an demain ce soir c'est
parce que c'est un principe c'est la
scène de la jcch est dommage je ne sais
pas je téléphonerai ce soit après
l'émission
bon
je compte sur vous ferme herbe
tiens carter décédé lé là la télé
puisque tu me tiens
non si ça doit se terminer comme hier
soir et hier pas dû être comptés c'est
qu'on prend on a eu le patron sur le dos
toute la journée je suis crevé je suis
annoncé toi alors merci
combien de sucre un seul ça suffit à
vous qui voulez vous parler c'est vrai
ça avec et par la chine
je ne sais pas moi il aurait fallu voir
le début de l'émission c'est pas là
enfin vous savez très bien à qui je
pense vous assure ma chérie mais cette
fois et à regarder j'en suis sûr en fait
tu deviens fou c'est de la télévision
web et télévision payet a regardé en
rouge tu m'attends au juge robert vous
auriez cru plus le voyage
[Musique]
le finir vaisselle ça va pas traîner
tout à peut-être que je recommence
attention juni
je sais ce qu'on dit déjà attention
voilà la jalousie comme le feu peut
raccourcir les cordes qui n'est elle est
fait sentir mauvais
tu m'a battu pardonne jamais n'aurait
cru ça toi comme moi c'est la télévision
c'est l'illusion du diamant s'accélère
c'est bien plus nerveux gagne du temps
je suis très content bon qu'est ce qu'on
fait demain demain la scène du crime
passionnel
attention vous concentrez vachement je
veux voir la haine jusqu'à la folie sur
le meurtre dans vos yeux compris bon on
va vous faire ça le dos râble sont des
anges à l'eau mais ce premier c'est pour
demain soir la scène du crime passionnel
ne vous inquiétez pas jouer la scène
comme d'habitude sans donner les veilles
nous interviendrons atteint messieurs le
principal il me faudrait dix hommes à la
disposition de m en somme c'est la télé
qui tue on se croirait en plein
feuilleton c'est complètement idiot
qu'est ce que je vous disais monsieur le
principal voilà pommiers qui découvre le
crime électronique exactement moins cher
muselier encore une fois je vous demande
d'agir dès ce soir
ah non pas ce soir c'est ce que promis
avant c'est exact il paraît
effectivement très urgent d'intervenir
au dessus ce soir j'ai mon feuilleton de
télé récemment fait muselier moment mais
je suis sincèrement navré
[Musique]
oui oui c'est elle même bonjour monsieur
qui est un appareil mon nom ne vous dit
rien je suis le président de
l'association de l'aide aux jeunes
ménages et vous venait justement de
gagner le premier prix de notre
association
c'est une commande de télévision à
distance et vous est pris de venir
chercher votre prix à 19 heures 30 au
magasin belge et bord actu monsieur ça
m'ennuie un petit peu parce que mon mari
rentre à 8h et très étonné de ne pas me
trouver là justement où vous lui ferez
la surprise sera très heureux croyez -
très heureux alors 19h30 sans faute bien
c'est entendu c'est parfait
bonjour monsieur j'ai reçu un coup de
téléphone avant la wii je viens chercher
mon cadeau excusez moi je suis un petit
peu pressés au revoir monsieur
[Musique]
alors au boulot on regarde la télévision
ça commence à quelle heure
et en attendant je pourrais être regardé
mon feuilleton c'est sur la première
ça ne me paraît pas très prudent
à
ici pommier la souricière est en place
rien à signaler pour l'instant
[Musique]
ce
allez a eu
et puis kif
politique
alors il dessine p
[Musique]
yes j'ai mis
jenny la femme du baer baer enfin si
bill la rue la femme de milliers
[Musique]
partout
je me vengerai wii u on ne peut sortir
non c'est le droit semble avec qui tu
étais un peu en retard il m'a fait
reporter sans doute oui avant d'évoquer
un peu traîné un industriel brésilien
c'était à ce moment d'ailleurs ne vous
fatiguez pas hubert je sais très bien
quoi ressembler votre industriels
brésiliens
c'est une petite blonde avec un chignon
des yeux marrons et une robe à volants
noire et blanche
et ça je le savais tu t'es avec lui le
revolver c'est le moment atone mais
qu'est ce que tu fais
vous plaît monsieur ton melon de
lectoure me l'envoie entendez le
cauchemar est terminé a été victime
d'une machination d'une machination
diabolique
s'il vous plaît à partir d'aujourd'hui
la septième chaîne interrompt ses
émissions définitivement si les voir
personne
[Musique]
passez moi albert je vous prie albert
oui vous pensez qu'ils se remettront et
diablement envolée bon bah il fallait
s'y attendre on va ce n'est que partie
remise
nous le retrouverons très bien albert je
suis content greu moins cher muselier où
vous allez pouvoir voir votre émission
doit être fini je vous en veux pas c'est
la fin
un jour le générique
ça va donner des regrets
go
[Musique]
quelle équipe
on
non c'est comme tout il a beaucoup de
modèles quand ils sont bons
en tout cas c'est bien mais y apprendrez
à la télé
[Musique]
oh